rolling out the red carpet for honored
guests three ministers and a host of
senior government officials welcome
passengers on a flight from Shaman in
southern China
gift bags and garlands but for the
tourists it was reward enough to be able
to travel overseas
here and here also have a beautiful
beach Delicious Fruit and everything is
well as the tourists moved through the
airport neither they nor any of the
other arrivals were required to show
vaccine certificates on Sunday evening
the civil aviation Authority had
hurriedly announced all passengers will
be required to show proof of vaccination
or immunity from covid-19 regardless of
their country of origin
but on Monday the health Minister
backtracked Thailand is dropping vaccine
requirements despite concerns that an
influx of Chinese tourists could bring
you variants of the virus by not
imposing restrictions speaking to Al
Jazeera the minister explained he wanted
to do everything to encourage visitors
to come we evaluate the risk and the
opportunity together
a newer evaluation is that there is no
risk
there is still risk but we have things
to overcome those risks you mean the
financial risks of not inviting people
pardon me you mean they find the
economic risks
this abrupt U-turn is an indication of
the fact that Thailand wants tourist
arrivals from anywhere in the world the
fact they're hoping for 10 million
arrivals from China by the end of the
year is also an indication of how
Reliant Thailand is now on arrivals from
China
other Asian nations are also hoping to
lure back Chinese tourists Japan was one
of the most popular pre-pandemic
destinations for Chinese Travelers
although now they'll have to show
negative covid-19 tests
but no entry requirements for Bali like
Thailand Indonesia has dropped all
coronavirus curbs although it expects
visitor numbers will remain low
Thailand however needs to get back to
pre-pandemic visitor levels fast
I'm happy the Chinese tourists are
coming back we haven't been able to make
a living we all suffered while they were
gone with only a million Chinese
arrivals expected in the first quarter
of the year that might be wishful
thinking but with the Beijing government
lifting all travel restrictions many
Asian countries will be hoping Chinese
visitors make the most of their Newfound
Freedom Tony Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok